i want to share some pretty bizarre uh
symptoms that relate to a b1 deficiency
the biggest thing you need to know about
b1 is that it relates to everything
nerve
okay so that includes the brain
so if there's a b1 deficiency
it can really affect
all parts of the nervous system you see
b1 is necessary to give energy
to a very specific cell called the
illegal dendrocyte okay what the heck is
the illegal dendrocyte
that is the cell that makes myelin
as in myelin sheath
decoding around the nervous system and
when that coating breaks down because
there's not enough b1
all sorts of things can happen and
that's what i'm going to cover today now
how do you become deficient in b1
well by consuming refined sugars
refined carbohydrates as in the bread
the pasta cereal crackers biscuits
waffles
anything with refined grains this is why
they enrich grains with synthetic
vitamins and minerals because it's
depleted with certain nutrients and then
when you consume it it can deplete you
of these nutrients all right another
common thing that will deplete your b1
is t
that tannins
in tea will deplete you of b1 as well as
the tannins in coffee as well as the
caffeine in both
sulphites
in
wine as well as
dried fruit okay and other things as
well alcohol which is also in the wine
raw fish
metformin chlorine as in tap water will
do it and a lot of medications like
antacid antibiotics especially cipro
diuretics
antidepressants like the ssris birth
control
seizure medications lupron which is for
endometriosis and conditions that relate
to early puberty and by the way that
drug has a tremendous amount of side
effects and then we have garsol and
cervarix which both if i'm not mistaken
and have been taken off the market but
they both
are vaccines for hpv the human papilloma
virus all right so let's first talk
about the first symptom and this would
be a symptom that's related to the
cerebellum okay the cerebellum it's the
back part of the brain that if you
looked at it it would look very similar
to
cauliflower but when you have a very
severe deficiency
in
b1
you get degeneration in the cerebellum
and the cerebellum controls motor
function it controls certain part of our
language it controls mood and attention
so when you reach out in space to get an
object you're using your cerebellum when
you're walking and you're coordinating
all the different muscles you're using
your cerebellum so when you
get a short-circuited problem in the
cerebellum an electrical problem because
the myelin is breaking down
you can get tourette's syndrome and that
is like random
vocalization of certain
things that a person says as well as
random twitching
and random motions that are just not
under the person's control then you have
another problem called ataxium that is
the gait problem if you're trying to
walk heel to toe you won't be able to do
it your shuffling your movements are
very erratic
and that is a cerebellum problem another
problem with the cerebellum it's
obsessive compulsive disorder that is a
symptom of a major b1 deficiency so you
can see that
b1 deficiency can affect a person
in different ways not always the same
way and realize i'm talking about very
specific symptoms that are related to
the cerebellum but there are many other
symptoms that are related to different
parts of your body that have nothing to
do with the myelin sheath okay another
symptom that's related to a b1
deficiency is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
because think about it we have
hyperactivity
this is an excessive motion state
with a lack of attention
both things are controlled by the
cerebellum
and then b1 is also
needed for the autonomic nervous system
because remember i talked about b1 is
everything neurological right the
autonomic nervous system is composed of
three different areas the sympathetic
nervous system the parasympathetic which
is rest and digest versus the
sympathetic which is flutter fight and
then the entire nervous system which is
everything to do with digestion so with
this system being dysfunctional you can
get what's called pots and pots is a
condition where you stand up and you
feel dizzy
you're you're going to collapse so you
have a very difficult time
standing up
it's actually a very devastating
condition which affects the autonomic
nervous system now even ms symptoms
because ms involves the brain as well as
modern sheath
can
mimic
a b1 deficiency so people that are
sometimes diagnosed with ms really might
just have a b1
deficiency and then we have fibromyalgia
symptoms too
that can mimic a b1 deficiency because
the relationship between the nerve and
the muscle connection and then we have
number eight which is chronic fatigue
syndrome
which also relates to the central
nervous system the nervous system powers
the energy through the body and so if
we're deficient in that electrical power
we're just going to be exhausted all the
time and then we have another part of
the nervous system called the peripheral
nervous system okay
and
a common symptom
with that is called peripheral
neuropathy
now that is usually a situation where
you see in diabetics where the bottom of
your feet become painful burning
numb
achy that can then also occur in your
hands okay because because the nervous
system especially myelin is destroyed
directly with sugar as well
so this is why you see this symptom in
diabetes but you can also have
peripheral neuropathy with a b1
deficiency that's created
another way
but also
high levels of sugar will create a b1
deficiency and also create peripheral
neuropathy now sciatic nerve is
insulated with myelin so some people
that are diagnosed with sciatica really
have
a b1 deficiency
that is acting like sciatica
so what is the solution to all this well
i already mentioned all the things that
can cause a b1 deficiency so you're
going to have to figure out which one is
causing yours but the other thing is
just to take some b1 make sure it's a
natural version not the synthetic
version
a good source of natural b1 also is
nutritional yeast it's not the only
source but it's a good source but make
sure you get the unfortified version
and then if you have a problem that's
anything related to the myelin sheath
okay which is a fat layer
i would recommend in addition to the
natural b1 i would take a fat soluble b1
vitamin called benfotamine and whatever
it recommends on the back of the label i
would times that by four
take four times as much because
if you take the fat soluble b1 called
benfotamine it will penetrate the
nervous system much better now the next
most important video to watch
would be my presentation at my summit my
keto summit on b1 check it out i put it
up right here